[Musique]
bienvenue c'est un lieu emblématique de
la capitale une institution du pari
érotique le 19 mai 1951 il ya tout juste
70 ans
un cabaret ouvrait ses portes à deux pas
des champs elysées le crazy horse à
l'origine
tout part de cet homme l'entrepreneur
alain bernardin est ce qu'il ya des
emplois classique
exactement comme alain gilles à paris
[Musique]
c'est lui qui choisit les noms de scène
sensuelle des danseuses elles sont
jeunes viennent de france ou de
l'étranger
elle s'appelle sophie palladium candy
capitole ou encore viola vibrato en 1970
cette ancienne danseuse d'opéra devenu
effeuilleuses était interviewé par le
journaliste pierre dumayet quand on vous
appelle viola vibrato parce que ça fait
jusqu'à présent ça me fait toujours
assez étrange
j'ai pas encore habitués terrible mais
l'une des plus célèbres danseuses du
cabaret c'est elle marie claude jourdain
dit
lova moor alain bernardin la repère au
début des années 70 et très vite elle
devient la meneuse de revue du crazy
horse novès est une épreuve de miroir
comme ça fait je tous les jeux wii ou la
libération c'est lorsque je pars en
vacances
j'essaie d'avoir une femme une chambre
dans un hôtel sans miroir et de ne plus
me garder d'oublier mon image
les années suivantes d'autres danses
suivront au gré des tableaux et des jeux
de lumières 1994 alain bernardin moeurs
et enfants prennent le relais jusqu'en
2006 date du rachat par un groupe belge
le crazy horse change de politique pour
la première fois des personnalités monde
sur scène à l'image de la chanteuse
arielle dombasle en 2007
c'est comme un écran c'est ton toutes
les femmes sont magnifiés c'est un
endroit où même la femme
on essaye de la rend belle
la robe magnifique c'est un endroit très
très idéaliste après arielle dombasle
clotilde courau en 2010 l'actrice
apparaît dans quatre tableaux créés
spécialement pour elle des gens qui
trouve ça formidable parce qu'une fois
de plus une si je ne suis pas là où on
m'attend
et puis à des gens qui trouvent que ces
déplacés mais moi je ne peux pas je ne
peux pas faire ma carrière en fonction
du site et des quads et qu'en dira-t-on
c'est ça depuis d'autres personnalités
ont foulé la mythique scène du cabaret
parmi elles le chanteur conchita woerth
en 2014 ou encore la danseuse dita von
teese en 2016
[Musique]